we're getting all sorts of bad answers
from the biden administration right now
uh ducey peter ducey at fox news just
grilled the new press secretary
corrine jean-pierre
he asked her
why is inflation so bad and the press
secretary gave this answer that the
white house has been pushing
on television in the press
which is look inflation is no worse here
than it is anywhere in the world it's
actually much much worse it's better
here than anywhere else and it's much
worse overseas and so stop complaining
about inflation and peter ducey
uh looks down at some of those numbers
he says wait a second that's just not
true
i did look globally though he says that
inflation is worse everywhere but here
that's not true the u.s has worse
inflation than germany france japan
canada india italy saudi arabia
so why is he saying i think what we are
saying is that uh
when you talk about inflation it is a
global thing and it is not just about
the united states this is something that
everyone is feeling because of coming
out of once once in a lifetime pandemic
because of the war that russia has
started in ukraine no that's not what
you said
you're changing your answer now
previously you said inflation is worse
everywhere else
come on it's relatively not that bad
here and then peter ducey says no it's
actually
relatively really bad here even relative
to other places in the world and then
karine john beer says no look we're just
pointing out it's like a global thing
know that that is not what you pointed
out that is not what you said
either you guys just got the numbers
completely wrong and you're incompetent
or you knew what the real numbers were
and you lied
either way not good either way does not
speak very highly of our current
ruling elite
it's a very it's a very different
country that we are living in right now
compared to
well
certainly compared to the country that
we had at the at the start of the united
states it's a very different country
that we're living in right now compared
to the country we had three years ago i
had this thought the other day i said do
you remember when trump was president
and pretty much everything was better do
you remember that seems so long ago
what about what about other historical
what kind of country
are we living in now and going to be
living in in the future i'm so glad you
liked that clip now
ring
subscribe
ding dong click that bell make sure you
get the notifications for the michael
knowles show then here's what i need you
to do i need you to copy this link and
then just text it and email it to all of
your friends there are people still in
america today around the world today who
don't listen to the michael knowles show
and i feel very sorry for those people
so make sure you send it around get
those notifications we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]